>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good afternoon.
Welcome to American
Furniture, 1650 to the Present,
with Oscar P. Fitzgerald.
I am Dr. Kimberley Bugg,
Chief of the Research
and Reference Division here
at the Library of Congress.
This afternoon's lecture is
part of an ongoing series
by the Humanities and
Social Sciences Section,
to highlight people such as
this afternoon's lecturer,
furniture connoisseur,
Oscar P. Fitzgerald.
From the splendor of the Main
Reading Room, the librarians
in Research and Reference
Division do a myriad
of activities.
We do everything from
making recommendations,
working with people
who have questions,
registering new readers,
and providing services
for the books, loaning
and retrieving things.
This afternoon's event
was coordinated, planned,
and put together by our
Reference Librarian,
Laura Berberian, who was just--
here she is-- in the room.
And our reference specialist,
Kathy Woodrell, who is in charge
of decorative arts
and architecture.
They selected items from rare
books and the general collection
for their accompanying
book displays,
so I hope you have
an opportunity
to stop by before you leave.
I'm going to ask that
you silence your phones
so you don't interrupt our
lecturer this afternoon.
And I am going to
have Kathy come up
and introduce him to us all.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Kimberley.
I'd also like to thank the
Print and Photograph Division
for lending an iconic chair and
ottoman by Charles and Ray Eames
for our lecture today.
I'm also very grateful
to the Rare Book
and Special Collections Division
for lending us such luminaries
as Chippendale, Sheraton,
and others,
and I want to extend thanks to
my colleague, Laura Berberian.
We worked together
on this presentation.
I'm honored to introduce
Oscar P. Fitzgerald.
I met Oscar about 20 years
ago when I took a class
on furniture connoisseurship
that he was teaching
through the Smithsonian.
At the Winterter Estate,
at the DAR Museum,
and at the Smithsonian's
Maryland storage facility,
we were actually encouraged
to upend exquisite pieces
of furniture for a closer look.
Somehow, when I try
this at home,
it's not that thrilling
[laughter].
And nationally known historian,
lecturer, and consultant
on American furniture, Oscar is
also faculty of the Smithsonian,
George Washington
University's Master's Program
in Decorative Arts,
and Design History,
where he teaches all
the furniture classes
from colonial to modern.
He consults on furniture
collections
in several historic house
museums, and he is the Curator
of Tengee [assumed spelling]
House, the official residence
of the Chief of Naval
Operations.
Oscar often relies on Library
of Congress collections
for his extensive research.
He lectured at the Library of
Congress in 2009 for his book,
Studio Furniture of the
Renwick Gallery, and since then,
he has produced New
Masters of the Wooden Box.
And these will be on the
table after the lecture.
And so other copies of his
books are on display here,
as well as a number of
wonderful furniture resources.
So, but today,
we are celebrating Oscar's
newest tome [laughter],
American Furniture
1650 to the Present,
a revision of his classic, Four
Centuries of American Furniture.
Copies of the new book are
available for sale and signing,
and in today's lecture, Oscar
will trace the development
and design of American
furniture by focusing
on the chair as a
furniture form.
Please join me in
welcoming Oscar Fitzgerald.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you so much, Kathy.
I really owe a great
debt of thanks to her
for putting this
together, and gathering
so many familiar faces, people I
haven't seen for quite a while.
And it has just been really
nice to be back at the library.
When I first got interested
in American furniture,
I was working at the navy yard
at the Naval History Museum,
and every lunch hour, I came up
and read the antiques magazines,
all the way from
1922 to the present,
and that was my introduction
to American furniture.
And I think the most interesting
one that I came across was
in the 1930s, and there was
this article about R. Edge,
a newly-discovered
cabinet maker,
and then in the next
issue, there was a sort of,
in the back page says
"oh, we made a mistake,
that's our edge is the right
edge," that was that [laughter],
and I would never have seen
that if I hadn't read all that,
all of those magazines
[laughter].
But today, my book is out, and
it's quite-- it's pretty big.
It's 850 pictures, and 600
pages, and one day, I was bored,
and I counted the words, there
are 250,000 words [laughter].
So I was thinking, well how
could I introduce the book
to you?
So I thought, well,
I'll focus on chairs.
And chairs really reflect the
changing styles over time,
and so we're going to take
just a quick look at chairs
through four centuries.
And some of the chairs were
based on some of the books
that we have in the back,
I was just telling Kathy.
I have seen the Dover reprints
of some of those books,
but never the real deal.
And it's quite exciting to be
able to see the real thing,
and I hope you enjoy
looking at those.
Well, every one of these systems
is a little bit different.
But anyway, there is
not much furniture.
There is no furniture that we
know of, before about 1650,
when the pilgrims landed in
James-- up in New England,
and down in Jamestown, and
Virginia, they were worried
about the Indians, and they were
worried about making a living
and trying to survive.
And of course, that's
a long time ago,
so nothing much has survived.
The earliest documented
furniture dates
from about the 1650s.
And...the first style
is the Jacob Ian style.
I like to use the
furniture styles.
Furniture was one of the
first decorative arts
that was studied.
And they were able to come
up with their own words
to describe the different
styles.
Other media, like silver,
and glass, and ceramics
and all, came along later.
And they started using
art history terms,
and the art history term
for this would be mannerism.
But I like the traditional
terms,
and I probably will
get those out by some
of the people and other media.
But anyway, if you talk about
mannerism, you always have
to say, well, but
I mean Jacob Ian.
But anyway, the first
style is mannerist.
And mannerism is sort of
playing around with classicism.
And from the 17th
century all the way
up into the early
19th century, really,
furniture was based
on classical designs.
Here are two chairs.
One on the left is made by
Turner's, who would work
on a lathe, and do fancy
decoration on the wood,
and the piece on the right
is known as a wainscot chair,
and that was done by joiners.
Cabinet makers don't
show up until about 1700.
They do special things
like dovetail joints,
and veneer, and inlay.
But the joiner, basically joined
the wood together with mortise
and joints and you can see
that in the wainscot chair.
You may wonder why is that
bottom panel not carved.
And the reason is that there
would be a big cushion in there,
about five pounds of
feathers, and so these chairs
that look pretty uncomfortable
were really quite nice,
actually in the 17th century,
and there weren't too many
of them, they honored guests,
you know, the governor,
and all the President, and
all the dignitaries would sit
in these chairs, everybody
else kind of sat on benches.
They did have some fancy
upholstered chairs.
These are known as
Turkey work chairs.
They look like oriental rugs,
and basically they were inspired
by those designs that we
were beginning to interact
with the middle east,
but these were done
in little cottage industries
around mostly in London.
People would come around,
collect the weavings,
and then sell them
to upholsterers,
and so there were some
upholstered furniture.
Very few have survived.
This is a very rare survival.
The next style is the
William and Mary style,
and it represents a radical
change in the design.
And you can see lots
of differences.
For one thing, the back
is caned, all of a sudden.
Where does caning come from?
Well even before William
and Mary took the throne,
Charles The Second was the king,
and he came in after Cromwell,
and Cromwell was kind of,
you know, didn't like a lot
of fancy stuff, and was
kind of not too much
of a fun guy [laughter],
but Charles the Second had been
spending his exile, or traveling
around enjoying Europe, and
he married Katherine Braganza,
who was from Portugal, and the
Portuguese were already training
in the far east, and
as part of her dowry,
she gave England the right to
trade in the far east as well.
So all of this, these
oriental things were coming in,
number one caning.
And also another thing,
too, if you notice,
the first chairs had
very straight backs,
kind of uncomfortable.
Now, the backs angle back.
Well, the Chinese have been
doing that for a long time,
and when the westerners
saw that, oh,
that's a pretty good idea,
we'll angle the back.
Already beginning in
the early 18th century,
the regional variations begin
to develop, and that really is
because of the different
people that settled
in the different cities,
and in the first half
of the 18th century, the
largest cities were Boston,
in New England, Newport,
New York,
Philadelphia, and in Charleston.
And here are three chairs,
the chair on the left is
actually a Philadelphia chair--
actually a Boston chair,
I'm sorry, and the chair
in the center was
made in New York.
And you see New York
kind of took a shortcut.
They couldn't afford
this particular chair.
Owner couldn't afford
the caning.
So they just continued the
balusters across the back,
and that was a very common
variation on those chairs.
And the chair on the right
is a Philadelphia chair.
Sorry. Philadelphia,
and then Boston.
Now you're totally
confused [laughter].
The Queen Anne style
comes in about 1725.
If you know your history, Queen
Anne actually ended her reign
about 1714, but the
early scholars
of the early 18th century
furniture got a little confused,
and they thought
that the styles,
really that the Queen Anne
style was a little later,
so it got misnamed.
But the style is
quite different.
William and Mary
furniture very much turn,
lost of oriental influence,
by the Queen Anne period,
it's all about curves.
And people really like modern,
really like Queen
Anne furniture.
I saw an ad one time
in the paper,
it said Thomas Chippendale would
have really loved this Queen
Anne chair [laughter].
Well, Chippendale didn't
really make this kind of thing
but it is very modern looking,
and you can see all the curves.
Even the seat is curved.
The seat is called
the compass seat,
because of the compass
you draw circles with,
and you lay out that
seat with a compass,
and that's just one
of the many curves.
Also if you notice, the feet,
the feet are trifid feet.
The trifid foot is a
little three-toed foot.
And that represents
the Irish influence.
And there is a very strong
Irish influence in Philadelphia.
Another thing that happens
in the Queen Anne period is
that mahogany is introduced
into furniture making.
In the 17th century,
the wood was oak.
By the William and Mary period,
people started using
lots of walnut.
By about 1720, mahogany
was the wood of choice
for the really best stuff.
Mahogany doesn't grow in
this country, of course.
It grows in the Caribbean, and
it's a very interesting wood.
It grows here, and there,
and you have to kind
of hunt it down in the forest.
It doesn't grow in groves.
By about 1800, mahogany
was beginning to disappear,
and so people thought we need to
start planting mahogany trees.
So they planted the mahogany
seed, nothing happened,
then they figured out, oh, it's
got to go through a bird first.
So they figured that out,
then they planted these
forests of mahogany trees.
And after about 20 years,
a fungus came along
and wiped them out.
And they're, oh, that's
why they're here and there.
So mahogany is pretty tricky.
But it was the wood of
choice, Santo Domingo, Cuba,
Honduras, were the main places.
Now, Windsor chairs
don't really follow the
stylistic progression.
Windsor chairs, if
we were sitting
in the 18th century
we'd probably be sitting
on Windsor chairs.
Windsor chairs were
public furniture.
The Continental Congress
actually sat
on Windsor chairs
in Philadelphia.
So they don't really follow
the stylistic progression.
A definition of a Windsor
chair is a plank seat,
with sticks into it, and so
you can have Windsor stools,
and in the center there, a
Windsor writing armchair,
and the chair next to the
writing armchair, you notice,
the turnings are very simple.
And in the 18th century, the
turnings were quite complex,
as you see in most
of those chairs.
But by about 1800, the Windsor
chairs become much simpler.
The chair needs to
become much simpler,
because the demand increased,
and it was easier to crank
out the chairs faster with
simpler turnings, and of course,
they made any excuse for that.
They say well that's
the oriental influence.
Make it look like bamboo.
And so much of design
is making a virtue
out of necessity
[laughter], we will see that.
We will see that
as we go through.
So the Chippendale
furniture comes in about 1760.
I was so excited to
see an original copy
of the Chippendales director,
I've seen the reprints a lot,
but nothing that is substitutes
for seeing the original,
and the cover is
quite spectacular too.
It has got the original cover.
Thomas Chippendale was
really the first person
to publish a book of designs.
There were other furniture
designs here and there
with other books, but
his was the first one
that was all furniture.
And it basically was a catalogue
for promoting his stuff.
And if you look at the
designs, they're quite complex.
And some people said
oh yeah, really?
You think he could
make that stuff?
And Chippendale's response
is yeah, I can do it,
but if you can't do it, you're
just not as good as I am.
And so they are quite
spectacular.
The design, most of the
designs are Rococo designs.
Very ornate.
Very much like the
chair on the left.
But there were two other
elements as well too,
and that was the Chinese
element, which you see
in the chair in the center,
and also gothic on the right.
And the title page actually
talks about Chinese, gothic,
and the modern taste, the modern
taste being the Rococo taste.
And notice, now, the curves
have begun to disappear?
The backs are very rectilinear.
The legs are straight,
Marlboro legs now,
and it's quite a different look.
And this is another-- based
on another design book,
this was by Robert Mann-Waring.
You can see the engraving
on the right.
And in Boston, they must have
had a number of copies of that,
because this chair was
very popular in Boston,
and you can see the direct
relationship to that.
To that design on the right.
Notice, also, the continuation
of the ball and claw foot.
In England, the ball and
claw foot disappears.
Chippendale doesn't show a
single ball and claw foot.
They were ball and claw feet
on American Queen Anne
furniture, but not that much.
But by the Chippendale period,
with economic things
getting better,
people could afford
the ball and claw foot,
even though it was a
little outdated in England.
And the regional
variations continue.
The chair on the left, again,
is the Philadelphia chair.
Very elaborate.
By the second half
of the 18th century,
Philadelphia replaces Boston as
the largest city in the country,
and the furniture, some
of the grandest Chippendale
furniture was made there.
In the center is New York.
In New York, had a very
strong English influence.
There was a royal
governor there.
There was a large
contingent of military there.
So the furniture
looks very English.
This is very English, with
the tassel ruffle on the back,
and you can't see on the
arms, but they're eagle heads
on the arms, and
very elaborate chair.
On the right is the
Boston chair.
The Boston chairs tend
to be much more delicate.
And you can see looking
at the seat rails,
how thin the seat rail
on the Boston chair is.
And because it was a little
lighter, they felt the need
to continue using stretchers
to reinforce the
chair to some extent.
Upholstered chairs continue.
These are, we call them
today, wing chairs.
Actually the wings in the 18th
century were called cheeks,
and they were really
designed as easy chairs,
and would be in the bedroom.
Not really in the parlor,
they'd be in the bedroom,
and it was designed so that if
you had a cold or something,
and you wanted to not wake up
while stuffed up, you could get
up and go to sleep
in your easy chair,
and that was the way people
really slept in that period.
And then there is this chair,
which is really a
very famous chair.
There is a book called Major
Francione's [assumed spelling]
Chairs, and these chairs, five
of them, appeared at auction
in England, consigned
by Major Francione.
And Joe Kendig was a big
dealer in Pennsylvania,
and he read about these
chairs, hopped on a plane
and thought oh, I'm
going to get a bargain,
people will think
they're English,
but they really are American.
Well, too bad.
Somebody knew about it,
and at the last minute,
they took them off the market,
sent them over to New York,
where they actually went about
$47,000 each in the 1980s.
You can see two of those chairs
in the Kaufman Collection today
at the National Gallery.
But it just shows that American
furniture could be as elaborate
or complex as any English
designs if there was the demand.
And in Philadelphia, sometimes
there was sometimes the demand.
We know that for sure
they're Philadelphia chairs,
because there is a
notation Hanlon--
and Hanlon reupholstered
those chairs in Philadelphia
in the early 20th century, so
there's no question about them.
Well, as I say, throughout the
18th century, it was classicism.
Classicism bits and pieces
of architecture, really,
by and large, if you think
of a desk and bookcase,
or a high chest, the
pediments just look
like architectural pediments
off classical buildings.
But at the end of
the 18th century,
neo-classicism is
introduced, and neo means new.
So what is new about classicism?
Well Robert Adam [laughs],
Robert Adam goes off
on the grand tour to
the classical remains
around the Mediterranean, and he
figures out that oh, you know,
if you go into these
classical buildings,
they look a lot different
than they do on the exterior.
I mean, you would never
believe what the exterior
of this building looks like by
looking at this room, I mean,
it's really very
nice, comfortable,
and very user friendly.
You go outside, you walk in,
it's pretty intimidating.
So that's what's new
about classicism,
and neo-classicism
was just that,
it was a lot more delicate,
more two-dimensional,
and still using elements
of classicism,
but as reflected on interiors.
And this is a chair
made in Hartford,
sort of a transitional chair.
You see it still has sort of a--
the little bit of rectilinearity
of the Chippendale
style, but there's a lot
of classical details, that
are in the back, particularly.
And we are delighted to be also
able to see some of the Sheraton
and Hepplewhite design
books in the back.
These were very popular.
Neither one of those
craftsmen, well,
actually Hepplewhite
was a craftsman,
but none of his furniture
really survived.
Sheraton really wasn't
so much into craft.
His book was called
The Drawing Book,
and that's exactly what it was.
It was a way to teach
craftsmen how to draw.
And the drawings would be ways
they would present their designs
to their customers.
But these two books
had a wide circulation,
and had a tremendous influence
on furniture in this period.
And even today, the
chair on the left,
we refer to as a
Hepplewhite style chair.
Whereas the one with the tapered
legs and urn-shaped back,
whereas the one on the
right, with the square back
and the turn legs is more
in the Sheraton style.
If you look at those design
books, they had same chairs
in both books, so it's really
not a valid distinction,
and I was reading one
of my students' thesis the
other night, and he said, oh,
he did a Hepplewhite style,
tall case, clock case.
So I went to my Dover reprint,
and Hepplewhite did not
design any clock cases.
So I mean, what did that mean?
It really meant nothing.
So it's better to just call
the stuff federal [laughter].
It's a neutral term,
you know [laughs].
There was, you know, American
furniture basically was,
you could argue, often,
that it's just rural
English furniture.
But we did some interesting
things, some unique things,
and the piece on
the left is, today,
often called a Martha
Washington chair.
It turns out, if you
go down to Mt. Vernon,
there is a Martha Washington
chair up in her bedroom,
and I went down to the
office there and asked them,
well when did Martha get that?
Well, Martha didn't
really get that.
We didn't get that until 1898,
and why they have
it there [laughs],
she didn't have a Martha
Washington chair actually
[laughter], but a
lot of people did.
And so what's unique
about it is [chuckles],
the chair on the right
is from about 1760.
And you see it is an
upholstered chair with arms.
It goes out of style in England,
but Americans kind of liked
that style, so we updated it
with these neo-classical
details, the higher back,
the nice turned legs, a little
bit of veneer on the legs,
and nice delicate arms, and
all of a sudden, a new chair,
mostly they were called lolling
chairs, because you could loll
around and be very
comfortable in them [laughter].
Well, the neo-classical
style is kind of complex,
because there are really
three phases in that period,
from about 1790 to about 1840.
The second phase
comes in about 1810,
and it's much more
three-dimensional.
The designs are based, some
of them are based very closely
on actual classical Greek
and Roman furniture,
and one of the most influential
was the Klismo chair.
The Klismo chair had saber legs,
like you see on this chair,
and you see also the carving,
the figures on the arms,
and the wire on the back, all
these details, from classicism.
At the same time,
Windsor chairs continue.
You see a Windsor
chair on the right.
The plank seat, with
the spindles.
Then a new type of commercial,
or sort of public
furniture comes in,
and these are called
fancy chairs,
and they're not really
very fancy, actually.
What they really
are is fanciful.
And the decoration is fanciful.
And of course, if you look
at that, you're thinking, oh,
that's a Hitchcock chair.
Right? Well, Hitchcock
was probably the largest
manufacturer of these chairs,
but there were really
hundreds of other makers.
So the proper term for that
is fancy chair, and you see,
instead of the plank
seat, it has a rush seat.
Which is very, very inexpensive,
and easily replaced.
And the stenciling was often
done by children, or women,
and you would paint
the gold paint on,
and you would pain
the varnish on,
then you would take bronze
dust, and it would look
like gilding on the back.
Well, the third phase is
the late empire phase,
and it is sometimes known
as the Grecian style.
And the Grecian style
is totally devoid of all
that elaborate carving,
and often Ormolu mounts,
and the fancy gilding,
and other decoration
that you see on the
second phase.
And it is just really
lots of veneers,
and lots of sculptural designs.
Sometimes today we
often refer to this
as the pillar and scroll style.
I don't see it so much in
a chair, but the pillars
and scrolls are on tables and
all sorts of other things.
This looks very much like the
chair that Lincoln was shot in.
And of course, you know he was
shot in 1865, this chair is
from about 1840, and the
story is that when he went
to Ford's Theater, of
course, he was a big guy,
and the little theater chairs
were just not quite right.
So they went down
in the basement,
and got out this outdated
chair, and put it up there,
and that is sometimes--
these are simply
called Lincoln rockers.
I saw one advertised at auction,
Lincoln's rocker, and I thought,
no, I don't think so [laughter].
That one is actually in
the Henry Ford Museum.
And just another variation
on a chair, which is new
to this period, the
Grecian style,
these are called gondola chairs.
And it's interesting,
the arm is--
forms actually the back
in one continuous design,
not two separate pieces.
Well, the Victorian style.
The Victorian style is
really misunderstood.
But actually, today, a lot of
people seem to be interested
in Victorian furniture because
there's a lot of it out there.
And of course it's named after
Queen Victoria, who lived from--
ruled from 1837 to about
1901, but it's very--
it's a complex period
[laughter].
So that to me is the best thing
about Victorian furniture,
the idea of surprise.
You're pretty surprised that you
could make a chair out of horns,
and then you start
looking at that chair,
and you see the other surprise?
The crest rail looks
like a pinned down hat.
I mean, how clever is that?
I mean, it's just
pretty bizarre, you know?
And this one is not
quite so surprising,
but you can see what
this was designed for.
You can see if you read closely
on the back, rail,
it says Albany.
And this comes off a
Hudson River steamboat,
which would take you off to
Albany, you know, which I was,
you know, I don't know why we
would want to go from New York
to Albany [laughter],
but anyway.
But anyway-- the other,
one of the influences
in this period is romanticism.
People were moving
to the cities.
The cities were really pretty--
not really that great a place
to live compared to the country,
but their jobs were there,
and anybody could make a good
living, but people were thinking
about places all over the world,
maybe Albany I guess [laughter],
but that influence,
the furniture.
Also the-- new materials
come in to use,
and of course, this is metal.
This was patented
by Thomas Warren,
it's called the centripetal
chair.
It's in use today.
If you go to the
Treasury Department,
or at least the last
time I went,
which was really a couple
years ago, the Secretary
of the Treasury sits
in a chair just
like that, or used to anyway.
It's really very comfortable.
I actually have one
in my office too.
It's really neat.
The springs on the bottom give
it a nice real spring to it.
And this one, innovation.
This is by George Huntzinger.
He did a lot of really
creative furniture.
And he did a lot
of patents, too.
And one of the patents was for
that diagonal brace on the side,
which makes the assembly of
that chair more efficient.
The other reason I show this is
that textiles become
very important.
You see huge floor to ceiling
draperies, you see wall
to wall carpeting, and you
see very elaborate upholstery
on the furniture, because
textiles become much cheaper.
In the 18th century,
really it's very expensive
to hand weave that stuff.
We saw the chair from the
17th century, very rare.
But by the 19th century,
upholstery becomes a big
deal, and very fancy.
And this is kind of
an American chair.
This is vintage really by
Michael Thone, he grew up,
he was born in Germany
and went to Vienna,
and came up with
Bentwood furniture.
And I show it because
bentwood furniture is still
available today.
It's probably next to
those plastic chairs
that you see everywhere.
Probably the most
made chair ever,
millions of copies were made.
And you can see one reason was
that they're easily
shipped around.
And he would make
them in Vienna,
send them over to New York,
then they would be
assembled and sold.
In the 1930s, the Thone company
was seeing the rise of Nazism,
and they decided to
get out of Germany,
and they came to this country.
And in the 1980s,
the Thone was bought
out by Shelby-William
Industries, and they are still
in production, the other part
of the company still exists
in Germany, but they're still
turning out these chairs,
and they're turning them
out here in this country.
And this one, other interesting
chair form that comes in,
in this period, is
children's furniture.
And why all of a sudden
children's furniture?
Well if you look at
art, and you look
at the way children are
depicted in the 18th century,
they're not depicted
as children.
They're depicted as
miniature adults.
There was no such
thing as childhood.
As soon as you could work in
the factory, work in the fields,
whatever, you were
out there doing it.
But in the 19th century, the
things become much more wealthy
and people can afford to let
their children stay at home.
And you know, that
trend today continues.
I mean, you have children at
home that are 35 [laughter].
But it starts in
the 19th century.
And well, the first revival
style is the gothic revival.
These are revivals,
they're not copies.
One of the things that people
criticize Victorian furniture
on is that they didn't
get it, you know,
that doesn't really look
like period gothic furniture.
Well that was the point,
they were inspired by gothic,
but they are making
it more robust.
They're making it
more interesting,
and you see it here,
with the rose window
in the back of the chair.
But in America, gothic
was not all that popular.
We don't have a lot
of gothic cathedrals,
other than maybe the
national cathedral,
which has only been
completed about 1900.
And so you do see it in
schools, and maybe in offices,
but not too much in parlors.
What you see in parlors is
more the Rococo revival,
and when you think of Victorian
furniture, some people think
of it as really Victorian
revival.
And in some times, you even
hear the term Belter furniture.
And that is named after
John Henry Belter,
who was probably the best known
maker of this type of furniture.
This is actually a Belter chair.
Part of a parlor
suite, and furniture
by the 19th century
was done in sets.
You would have a sofa, a
man's chair, a woman's chair,
then four side chairs,
where the--
you know, lesser
people would sit.
And these would be all matched.
And again, a symbol or function
of the wealth of
the 19th century.
The thing about Rococo
furniture, if you look at that,
it's a lot of fruits
and flowers,
and it's really beautifully
carved.
It's all hand carved.
People think 19th century
furniture is all industrial,
you know, factory made,
but all that carving,
the first carving machines, they
don't turn up until the 1890s,
so this is all hand carved
and beautifully done.
More complex and really finer
than 18th century carving.
Well, also popular in this
period was the renaissance
revival, and renaissance
furniture is quite different.
Instead of all those nice
curves of the Rococo,
it's now much more angular,
and based a lot on designs
from the renaissance, and
you can see the difference,
it's got little ears,
that's one of the signs
of renaissance revival
furniture.
It has a little drop
on the skirt,
and the legs are straight,
instead of the curved legs.
This one happens to be by John
Geldhof [assumed spelling],
who worked in Newark,
just outside of New York.
But renaissance revival
furniture is very complex.
There is some furniture that
is very heavily influenced
by the Egyptian interest.
The first exhibits in New
York, at the Met, were in 1852,
and in about 1879, they
installed an obelisk,
in Central Park, and Egyptian
interest was quite strong,
and you can see it
here in this furniture.
But still, very angular,
turned legs,
and little drops on the skirt.
Another phase of the renaissance
revival was harkening back
to Louis the Sixteenth
furniture.
The Rococo revival goes
back to Louis the Fifteenth,
which is Rococo furniture
in France.
Louis Sixteenth is
more neo-classical
and much more angular,
and you can see
that this chair almost looks
like it might have been made
in the late 18th century instead
of in the mid-19th century,
so there is an influence, from
Louis Sixteenth furniture,
and also classicism in
general, and you see the urn--
the shape on the back, and
that is sometimes referred
to as neo-grec, the
new Grecian style,
you know from earlier
neo-classical period.
So renaissance revival
has three phases.
And then, well, people
kind of got tired of all
that revival stuff, and you
had William Morris coming along
and saying, you know,
it's really terrible what
these people are doing
in the factories, they're
just putting the eyes
on the Mickey Mouse doll all day
and it's really kind of boring,
and we ought to go back to the
middle ages, when the designer
of the furniture
was also the maker,
which really was never the case,
the maker was always being told
by somebody, mostly the
architect, what to do.
And it was pretty hard
work in those days.
And things were really better
for the workmen in
the 19th century.
But William Morris kind of
brainwashed a whole generation,
you know, that factories are
bad, and all of that extra,
ornament, and all that stuff.
So he came up with
a lounge chair,
which was called
the Morris chair.
And people always cite that,
oh, how creative and wonderful.
I was looking through another
one of the period design books
from 1829, and in William
King's design book is a Morris
chair [laughter].
So he just simply copied
that idea, I guess.
A Morris chair, this is, was
the design in Morris' company,
and you can see the back does
recline at different angles,
and that is what makes
it a Morris chair.
And notice also,
the introduction of
oak in furniture.
We will talk about arts
and crafts furniture,
which is primarily oak.
That is because all the walnut
was used up in the 19th century.
They had to come up with
another wood, and oh, oak!
And it's so wonderful,
because it's the same ones
that they used in
the middle ages,
how convenient for
that [laughter].
Well, the person that
popularized a lot
of these ideas was
Charles Lot Eastlake.
And I was thrilled
to see a manuscript
that it's not his hints
on household taste,
but another one by, I don't
know if it is his wife, or who,
I need to really do
some research on it,
but full of furniture designs
that were used as design sources
in this period, but
this one comes
from his Hints on
Household Taste.
It is how to furnish your house,
and you can see how close it is
to the piece on the right.
The little spindles
are kind of a signature
of the Eastlake style.
Much thinner, much more
delicate, still turn lay,
still angular, but
much lighter in feel.
And within this period, we
call it the Eastlake style,
but really a better term
is the Queen Anne style.
It gets very confused, but
the Queen Anne style was
just revivalist.
They were coming up with
all kinds of design sources,
and one of the major design
sources was the far east again,
and particularly Japan.
And in the 1850s, Japan was
sort of open, a little bit,
not really very much-- I
think the treaty said if one
of our sailors gets
marooned on your island,
you will liberate them, and
that was about the extent
of the opening, but the
Japanese got the message,
because when Perry arrived
with about 20 war ships,
they thought maybe we need
to think about modernizing
and defending ourselves
from this.
So they discovered, Perry
discovered in Japan,
the Japanese discovered the
west, and they began to exhibit
in the World's Fairs,
which began in 1851
in the Crystal Palace in London.
They didn't exhibit there,
but they did exhibit in 1867,
and in 1876, in Philadelphia,
the Japanese Pavilion caused
a big stir, and as a result,
lots of furniture had
these oriental influences,
as you see, on these chairs.
And then there was also this
guy, called Oscar Wilde,
my namesake [laughter],
who went around the country
preaching art for art's sake,
and up to that period,
furniture,
and all the decoration,
they were used as sort
of cultural conditioning, as a
way of transferring the culture
to generations and by the late
19th century, they thought,
you know, we ought to just
think about this stuff as art.
It's beautiful.
That's all we need
to worry about.
We don't have to worry
about we're trying
to educate the public.
So at the high end of the
market, the aesthetic movement,
were the herder brothers.
And the herder brothers,
interestingly enough,
if you've ever heard
of Christian Herder,
who was the Secretary of
State under Eisenhower.
That's the same family,
actually.
But the Herder brothers,
produced, in my opinion,
some of the best furniture
ever produced in America
on a large scale, and this
is one of those chairs.
I saw that chair.
I could have bought that chair
at the New York Antique Show.
I was sitting in
the chair, I said,
well how much is this chair?
They said, oh, it's
a million dollars.
A million dollars
[laughter], I don't think so!
Well no kidding.
And it's a fabulous chair.
And there is not a
straight line in it.
When there are no
straight lines,
it's very difficult to make.
You see the little fetlock
from a horse, you see in the,
on the seat rail, these
mother of pearl orbs,
and if you look closely,
they're kind of hanging
as if these are orbs
hanging on the seat rail.
Another detail, which
is kind of interesting,
the orb in the center is
kind of hanging there,
surrounded by a ribbon, and then
you look up at the seat rail,
the state rail, the rail
just right above the seat,
and that square plaque, and
it's surrounded by a ribbon too,
but if you look closely,
it's surrounded--
that ribbon has turned
into a snake
and it's really,
really very clever.
And as I said in the late 19th
century, it's lots of revivals.
And one of the most popular
revivals was the colonial
revival, and this is
clear colonial revival.
You can see the date, 1876,
and wicker furniture
becomes very popular too.
Wicker appears, really, well,
you know, Moses was found
in the bull rushes
in a wicker cradle,
actually so it goes way
back to classical periods.
It was shown at the 1870--
1851 Centennial Exhibit,
but it becomes very popular
in the late 19th century,
into the 20th century, and
a good example of that.
And again, another
surprise, this is,
of course, Colonial Revival.
This belonged to our
mother, as you can see,
it says right there,
our mothers.
And we just broke up her--
weaving equipment and
made it into a chair.
And then we came up with
a new type of chair, too,
this is a platform rocker.
And well, all of that
is sort of just myth.
There was a company that made
this stuff, and they didn't go
around collecting
old spinning wheels,
they actually made
the stuff to make
into the chairs,
like you see here.
And the platform rocker was
a new idea, because you know,
people came over, and
Americans loved rocking chairs.
We've always loved
rocking chairs.
The Europeans were horrified.
That's pretty, you know, pretty
boorish, to be sitting there
in a rocking chair [laughter],
so some people [chuckles],
really, that's what they said.
So some people decided, well,
we'll make it a platform rocker.
It won't be quite so obvious.
You can just rock
back and forth,
and it doesn't mess
up the floor, either.
That's another good
thing about it.
Well, again, the bridge
between Victorian revivals
and modernism is kind of Haute
Nouveau, people were trying
to find a new source for design.
Instead of reviving stuff from
the past, they were trying
to find something new, and
the new stuff was, well,
you could look at geometry,
which we knew, or you could look
at nature, and so
Tiffany looks at nature.
You can see on the--
you can't see it,
but it's actually carved
flowers on the crest rail.
And then geometry in
those little squares.
Those are micro-mosaics.
Just tiny little pieces of wood
based on designs in Bombay,
that were imported, and
sometimes just copied,
so it's got both,
the Micro Mosaic,
geometry and the plant forms.
And just, another maker that
made that kind of thing,
this is Charles Roloff.
He's a very interesting guy.
He started out as an actor,
and then he got married,
and his wife said,
you know what buddy?
I don't want to be
married to an actor,
you need to find another job.
So he'd been a kind
of amateur craftsman,
so he started making
craft furniture,
and you can see this
pretty ornate stuff.
Very collectible.
He was one of the few people
who received international
recognition, and he won a prize
at the Turin Exhibit in 1902.
Other people, the
Greene brothers,
out in California made furniture
also with art nouveau details.
You can see the inlay right
on the splat right there,
it's a little hard to see.
The other influence here
is the Danish influence,
because the man that made
their furniture was Peter Hall,
who was trained in Denmark,
so the furniture has a very much
Danish Scandinavian look to it.
Well, the arts and
crafts movement comes,
and it is sometimes
called Mission Furniture.
And the reason for that
is that in the beginning,
this chair was sent to a
guy named Joseph McCoo,
not this particular chair, but
the one that it is based on,
and McCoo thought, well,
that's pretty neat.
I'll start making that chair,
and it was a very big success,
and so that was the mission,
it came from not really
a California mission,
it was a [inaudible] church
they were building out there,
but you know, sounds nicer
to be from a mission.
And, but the most
popular person,
the most well-known person
making this stuff was
Gustav Stickley.
And he was well-known, because
he started publishing Craftsman
Magazine in 1900, promoting
all these new ideas.
And generally, it was
very simple, unadorned,
no decoration, but
in 1903 and 1904,
he hired this guy
named Harvey Ellis.
And Harvey Ellis
was kind of a drunk,
but very creative guy
[laughter], and said, you know,
we need to make this
stuff more interesting,
we need to put inlay on it.
So for a short period of time,
some of the furniture has inlay,
and that brings the
biggest prices.
Unfortunately, as I say,
he was an alcoholic.
He died, and after about
a year, and that was it,
and Stickley quit doing that,
went back to the
plain furniture.
He had four brothers,
one of whom was Albert,
who was in partnership with
Leopold for a short period
of time, and Albert had done a
lot of traveling around Europe,
so his furniture is much more
interesting and has decoration
on it, in contrast to
the Stickley stuff.
Then, of course, Frank Lloyd
Wright, who is really one
of the pioneers in modernism.
And this is a chair
he designed in 1904,
and he doesn't get the
credit that he deserves.
You see on the right, the
famous red blue chair,
of Garrett Rietveld.
And that one is the one that all
of history of modern design--
but the truth, the story is,
the client came to Rietveld,
who was working in the distill
movement in Holland, and said,
you know, I want
you to make a copy
of that Frank Lloyd
Wright chair.
And so you can see, it
is pretty close to it.
is pretty close to that.
And as you also, as I say,
it's based on geometry.
Well, modernism comes
in after World War One.
All of these, the arts and
crafts movement, all of that,
people associated
that with Europe,
and Europe caused World War One.
And it was a terrible disaster,
and our troops went over
and fought and said, man,
if this is European stuff,
we want nothing to
do with Europe.
So they came back and started
looking at American culture,
and Colonial revival
had already been going.
And that took off.
And here, you see,
just an example
of a Wallace Nutting high chair.
And you could buy that high
chair for [inaudible] dollars
in the Wallace and Edison
Catalogue in the 1920s.
That's Winterthur, and it's
really a fantastic chair.
The thing about Wallace Nutting,
he was very knowledgeable.
He was so knowledgeable,
that his furniture is
really a composite.
It's better than anything they
ever did in the 18th century
and that's why they thought
it was a great example
of Winterthur, until
they realized
that oh, it's 1920, not 1820.
Well, Europeans also were tired
of all that stuff from the past,
and they wanted something
new, and so one of the centers
for the new was the Bauhaus,
the new house, and the idea was
to bring good design
to the masses.
And the idea was to use
technology, and strip all
of that [inaudible],
again making a virtue
out of necessity, because all
those guys that could make all
that fancy furniture got killed,
and we have to build houses
and furniture fast, and so you
can't waste time putting a lot
of ornament on it.
So less is more.
Isn't that wonderful?
Do away with all that ugly
ornament, and you know,
make it out of metal, and then
these are [inaudible] Broyer's
Seska [assumed spelling]
chairs, he was the head
of the furniture
department at the Bauhaus,
and very revolutionary.
Who could think that you could
make a chair with two legs?
And it was pretty revolutionary.
And so this high
tech look was one
of the elements of modernism.
Another person at the Bauhaus,
who was the head of the Bauhaus,
was [inaudible] and he
made the Barcelona chair,
which is the icon of modernism,
for the 1929 Barcelona
Exhibition, for the King
and Queen of Spain,
to open the Fair.
And it was pretty neat,
they've restored that building,
and actually sat
in a reproduction
of the Barcelona chair, and went
back, but they're still in use,
and again, that high tech look.
But with a little
classical design.
It almost looks
like a [inaudible]
another classical chair.
Americans did metal
furniture, too.
Warren MacArthur, instead of
using chrome-plated steel,
used aluminum, and aluminum
is very hard to weld,
and you can see the
joints are kind of joints
that don't require welding.
We had a kind of
our Bauhaus, too.
Which was known as the Cranbrook
School in just outside Detroit,
and the head of the Cranbrook
School was Eliel Saarinen,
who was a very famous
Finnish architect.
If you have ever
been to Helsinki,
the railway station was his,
that was his masterpiece.
Really fantastic.
He came over into Detroit
to do some lectures,
and the son of the head
of the Detroit Press was very
impressed, and told his dad,
you know, we need
to get this guy
over to head the
school, so he did.
And this was the chair that
he used in his dining room.
And we talked about
the high tech look.
The other way of modernism was
to make it a little
more humanistic.
Instead of metal, use wood, and
instead of just straight lines,
we can make it a little organic.
And that was sort of
the Scandinavian look.
And this was done by a
guy named Russell Wright,
who pioneered that look.
And, okay, and one more
example is the streamlined look.
This is the airline chair, where
Ken Weber, also an emigrant
from there, and that was
also a marvelous design.
Modernism, the Danish
modern continues
with Danish modern chairs.
This is a Hans [inaudible]
chair.
And I can't stop without
mentioning Charles
and Ray Eames [assumed
spelling].
This is almost a clich now,
but when you look at that chair,
it's a fabulous chair,
it's like, you know a kind
of a dragon or what
kind of figure is that?
Using both wood and
metal, and no upholstery,
but it's very comfortable.
If you look at that little black
disc on the back, it's rubber.
And it gives a little bit.
And Eames was known for
the first plastic chair,
that reads as plastic.
If you look at fiberglass, it's
pretty ugly, but he figured
out how to put a skin coat on
it, and could do it that way.
And he even did children's
furniture with a little heart,
and modernists went ballistic.
What are you decorating the
furniture with [laughter],
and Charles said, everybody
loves children honey [laughter],
and I'll stop with
the Eames lounger,
which we have an example of.
It's interesting.
I'm sure this is rosewood.
You can notice rosewood
is usually very dark,
but this has a nice
patina on it.
And it's a fabulously
comfortable chair.
And if you ever-- well the only
downside is, if you get in it,
it's a little hard
to get out of it.
So don't sit in it.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Any questions?
>> Yes, thank you
again, Dr. Fitzgerald,
for such an informative lecture.
We have time for
a few questions.
If anybody has questions
right now?
>> A lot of those pictures show
the chairs a little [inaudible].
>> Yes.
>> Is that how they
originally were intended,
or why are those little
[inaudible] there?
>> Yeah, well you know,
we associated casters
with [inaudible] furniture,
and a lot of furniture
[inaudible] had casters,
but the truth is, casters
go back to the 18th century.
The early ones were
made out of--
they'd take strips of leather,
and wind them into a circle,
and they were often
used as casters.
So there were casters
in the 18th century.
It's kind of an expensive
detail, and by the 19th century,
the technology was such that you
could make them less expensive.
The other reason that they're
so common in the 19th century is
that by the 19th century, we
began to see central heating,
and so instead of having to
huddle at the fire all the time,
you could move the stuff around,
you know, you could put it
by the fire, you could go near
the window, and it was nice
to be able to roll the furniture
around, and very convenient,
and so a lot of the
furniture does have that.
A lot of them have been removed,
because they're associated
with Victorian furniture,
but even today,
lots of furniture has
casters on them too,
just so that you can
move them around.
Because furniture
is pretty heavy.
Yeah. Good question.
Any other questions?
Yeah, yeah.
>> You were here some months
ago and gave two talks, I think,
about a week or two apart.
Are you coming back anytime
soon for a continuation or?
>> [Laughs] Well, you may--
I think you may be thinking--
I wasn't here at the
Library of Congress,
I was at the Smithsonian
American Art Museum--
>> That might have been it.
Yeah, yeah.
>> [Laughs] That
was another program.
I've been doing a lot of
lectures for the book.
I've been trying to think, I
think the next one I'm going
to give is at the
Alexandria Library,
it's about the April
27th, 28th, and I'm going
to be doing a book signing
at the New York Antique
Show in May.
And down in July, I'm going
down to the only other Chitaqua
that survived, down
in Tennessee,
and then there is a program in
North Carolina, for Appraisers,
I'm going to be doing
some series there.
So a lot of lectures.
But anyway, anybody wants to
hear me talk about furniture,
I'm happy to do it [laughter].
Thank you.
Anything else?
Yes?
>> When you hear the phrase
[inaudible] furniture,
is that a style,
or just a location?
>> Well, it's really both.
In mid-19th century, the
furniture industry moves west,
primarily because being nearer
the source of raw materials,
which were forests, and the
Midwest, and Grand Rapids,
is surrounded by forest.
What also made that
possible was the railroads.
So that instead of
having to, you know,
just make furniture locally,
they could ship it all around.
So Grand Rapids, even
though it's fairly isolated,
it's connected to
the railroad system,
and it became proportionally
larger center
of cabinet making
in the country.
It wasn't bigger than Chicago,
but Chicago was like ten times
as big and tons of
population, so Grand Rapids,
it was really synonymous
with furniture.
So that's one reason that
the term becomes synonymous
with furniture.
And much of the furniture being
made there was mass produced
furniture, and so it
was sort of ordinary.
It wasn't the high-end really
expensive stuff, which was found
by the Herr brothers in
New York, or something,
like they had rich clients.
This was the mass produced, for
the masses, and so the term,
Grand Rapids Furniture
gets associated
with that style of furniture.
It's mostly in the
Eastlake style,
and also the revival styles
that you see, so it's both.
It's a furniture place,
but it connotes that kind
of mass produced furniture
of late 19th century.
Yeah.
>> You said the [inaudible]
examples of Federal,
would that also be
the same as Georgian,
or what are the differences
between Federal and Georgian?
>> Well, in England,
it actually--
most of the styles
originate in France.
In terms of the neo-classical
designs, that really,
you can credit Robert Adams with
that, and sometimes people refer
to that style as
the Adams style,
because he was really the
person that generated that.
Georgian furniture, when you
talk about Georgian furniture,
usually refers to
mid-18th century furniture,
but there were four George's,
so if it's George
the Fourth furniture,
it would be early 19th
century, and same style,
but you don't usually
see that associated
with neo-classical furniture.
It's usually more of the
Chippendale furniture,
from the mid-18th century.
That's Georgian furniture.
And as I said, there
were four George's
so English furniture uses those
terms for the Georgian style,
but by the neo-classical period,
it's often referred
to as [inaudible].
All right.
Thank you.
>> Thanks.
I'd like to thank the audience
today for your presence.
You're invited to the
author's book signing, as well,
copies of the book are available
for purchase, to your left,
and to your right, we
have books from rare books
and special collections, and the
general collections, on display.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.